welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka
america's ass hole and this video we're
breaking down
our best theories on falcon and the
winter soldier there's a brand new
trailer out which gives some hints
towards what could be happening
and we've got a lot to discuss before
episodes five and six air
we'll also be discussing some leaks
towards the end of the video
but i'll give you a heads up before we
get to those however
heavy spoiler warning now in full effect
for everything up to the end of episode
4.
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into the breakdown
okay so on monday the 12th of april
marvel dropped a mid-season trailer for
falcon in the winter soldier
that gave us a good glimpse at what
could be coming down the line
this teaser showed several never before
seen scenes
including one in which bucky and sam
went to take the shield from john walker
this is something that the pair have
discussed throughout the series and it
seems like
it's finally going down it's on now
episode 4 ended with a big moment that
was extremely similar to the ending of
civil war
in both the film and show we saw as a
captain america slammed his shield down
on someone
and whereas steve decided to leave
before killing them
walker flags smashed some dude's head in
the parallels are gonna seemingly
continue
and in the teaser we see sam and bucky
about to go toe-to-toe with walker
this shot is very similar to something
out of civil war namely the final battle
in which it was cabin bucky versus tony
now we know from other moments in the
trailer that at this point
the shield is covered in the blood of
the flag smasher that was killed doing
what he did best
which was looking up to captain america
therefore i'm guessing that this fight
happens immediately after the ending of
episode 4
and that sam and bucky attempt to take
the shield from him straight away
now i believe that jon will actually win
this fight and this is why we see him
later on in his military uniform
saying that he's captain america this
shot seems to be at a courthouse
and it could also be the moment when we
saw bucky looking incognito in the
trailers
though it appears to be a different
location it would make sense to have him
too keeping an eye on walker
after the fight i'm guessing that walker
beats them and returns to the us
and then perhaps he visits the
smithsonian where bucky attends
and this is why he looks so be up about
it it could also however be a flashback
to when sam handed over the shield to
the museum
and perhaps it's an angle on that moment
that we just haven't seen yet
now we do see walker in the trailer
during its night scene throwing the
shield
so it seems like he does retain it
however it's also possible that sam and
bucky managed to get it back
which is why there's a big part in the
first trailer of sam trading with it
now shout out to johnny wilkinson on
twitter for pointing out that
if you look closely at the shield in
these night scenes you will see that
it's cracked in the middle
i'm guessing this is off the earlier
fight and just in the same way that the
paint is starting to rust away
the image of captain america is too now
this also highlights that the shield
is a slightly different one to the one
that steve used to have as
in end game it did of course get snapped
in half by thanos
therefore the one that steve gave sam at
the end of end game has been pieced
together slightly differently
which does explain why it's split in
this formation
now if i was to hazard a guess over the
order of things i would say that i think
that walker will beat the two at the
start of the next
episode he will return to america have
even more of a blowout at the government
who will try and take the shield off of
him
and this will lead to the fight in the
street that we see this echoes the
moment that sam and us agent fought one
another in sam wilson captain america
so there is definitely precedence for it
in the source material
and i think episode 6 will focus on the
power broker and flag smashes
with sam becoming captain america during
that entry
now if you look closely at the shield in
the street then you will see that it's
actually a different version to the one
that walker has been carrying throughout
the series
what may happen is that either sam or
the government take it back
and we then see walker do his big thing
about being captain america
after he's stripped of the mantle he
could then recover the one from the
ending of end game
wherever it is piece it back together
and then continue his reign of terror
this would allow sam to go off and train
with the one that we've seen him using
in the trailers
and it makes more sense that there's now
two shields knocking about a huge shout
outs to josh from den of the nerds was
saying that he thinks sam will forgive
walker
and this will show that he is right to
become captain america
steve saw that deep down sam was better
than most people
and that's why he chose him to take over
the mantle hell
when we got to see his home life in
winter soldier he was even helping
troops that had mental health issues
because of the combat they'd seen
so i think if anyone can forgive walker
it's definitely gonna be him
josh and i did a big stream yesterday
talking about the upcoming episode
and he actually thinks that sam won't
take the shield by force
and instead he'll convince walker that
he's the right person to bear the mantle
and this will make jon give it to him he
thinks that sam will then ask for his
help in fighting the flag smashers
so it will be somewhat redemption for
the character and will mean that walker
becomes their ally instead
josh very much said that he thinks the
trailers are making it appear like
there's gonna be a big fight
but that they're simply doing that to
subvert our expectations
and i do actually really like this
theory now as for the other characters
i think it's pretty safe to assume that
sharon carter will get her pardon
after sam insists that she's a good guy
again
they will let her back into the country
so that she can see her family
however i don't think that she will join
the government and with shield disbanded
in this mcu timeline
it is possible that she will continue to
work as some sort of anti-hero
perhaps she might even join a certain
group that we'll talk about in just a
bit
but that's just something to bear in
mind as we go towards the finale now as
for bucky
i think that when this is all over he
will return to mr nakajima
and show up like hey mate i did kill
your son
yeah it was me now throughout this
season his arc has very much been about
him forgiving himself
and also seeking the forgiveness of
others though this plotline was
dropped pretty quickly after episode 1
the thread is still
very important to the character's
development i think when sam becomes
captain america
it will show bucky that steve wasn't
wrong about him
which in turn will make him realize that
he wasn't wrong about him either
he'll then go back out with that girl
i'm guessing and the guy will finally
get his happy ending
yay now as for zemo i feel that he will
end up joining or perhaps
even helping to form the thunderbolts
though we don't have definite word on
whether they'll be in the mcu or not
due to taskmaster elena bulova and zemo
all appearing in phase four
i think it's safe to assume something is
being set up to bring the group together
personally i think the series might end
with semo back in jail
and then thunderbolt ross could go and
visit him and ask him to join their team
this is pretty close to the post-credits
scene involving deathstroke at the end
of arkham origins
and though it is though it's pretty much
just the exact same thing that happens
in that
i think it would make a lot of sense the
thunderbolts are pretty much the suicide
squad version of the avengers
and with nick fury going to recruit tony
at the end of iron man
it makes sense to repeat this sort of
aesthetic when forming that new team
now for the rest of the video i will be
discussing some of the toy leaks that
give away what happens to sam and john
walker
so if you don't want anything spoiled
then cheers for sticking up until this
point
i'll see you on the next one anyway from
the toys we know that sam
does become captain america and that he
gets his white suit from the comics
whether this happens after he beats
walker or not we don't know yet
but at some point in the series he will
be donning it
i can kind of see him perhaps wearing it
after the end of episode 5
which is when i'm guessing walker drops
the mantle
it would be great to get a full finale
where he wears it but if not
i guess he will be putting it on in the
upcoming movies now as for walker we do
know from the toys that he will become
his alter ego u.s
agent in the comics after jon had the
mantle of captain america taken away
from him he became
somewhat of an anti-hero wearing black
and red he's performed as a mercenary
and also been there when cap has needed
him with him now being a super soldier
the world will of course always have a
use for him and therefore
i think he might even become a
thunderbolt member or potentially go off
and do his own thing
now one thing to notice about the toy is
that he doesn't have a shield
typically in the comics the character
carried a vibranium disc
but it looks like as far as the series
is concerned
that he won't be getting that yet i kind
of feel like he might in one of the
upcoming projects
but for the meantime that's about as far
as things will go
now obviously i'd love to hear your
thoughts and theories so make sure you
comment below and let me know
as a thank you for interacting with the
video you'll be entered into a prize
during the 30th of april
in which we're giving away three copies
of zack snyder's justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is like this make sure you
subscribe with notifications
on and drop a comment below with all
your crazy fan theories
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so that's you
then message me on twitter at heavy
spoilers
and something else to watch then make
sure you check out our breakdown of all
the details we know about the episode 5
cameo
which will be linked on screen right now
we've gone over what we've heard from
the best sources to give you
as definitive of an answer we can get at
the moment so definitely check it out if
you want to know more
that out of the way thank you for
sticking through the video i've been
paul
i'll see you next time take care peace